tu reviens tu étais parti dans terre
inconnue alors c'est pas extrait d' eric
lopez
alors ouais t'as pas il n'y a pas fait
partie du voyage c'est vrai que ça ça a
été un truc dont tout le monde a parlé
il paraît qu'à la conférence de presse
vous ne vous êtes pas parler frédéric
lopez et toi donc c'est parti avec le
nouvel animateur dans terre inconnue
alors on a le teaser de l'émission qui
était dispo regardez je propose une
expérience un peu extrême je ne parle
pas en a rappelé m
avec franck gastambide taxi vers
l'inconnu bientôt sur france tf1 et
france télévisions à ce qu'on va voir un
extrait en exclusivité dans un instant
le rendez vous en terre inconnue avec
rentrer même toi tu ne l'as pas vu non
je te le dis et merci à frédéric lopez
merci à france télévisions on va te le
montrer dans un instant juste est ce que
c'est vrai tu es vraiment voilà ça te
gêne et que fred lopez ne viennent pas
avec toi mais complètement inapte
vraiment c'est à dire que évidemment que
c'est un détail de ce que j'ai vécu
ensuite qui est la plus grande aventure
de ma vie et qui était un choc pour moi
et j'ai encore beaucoup de mal à en
parler mais en revanche ça tu vois le
teaser parle pour lui quoi ressemble
c'est un espèce de saut dans le vide et
ton seul repère te dit je pars pu alors
quelques temps après ça y est tu oublies
et puis et puis raphaël est un mec
incroyable qui va avec même un plus
grand voyageur que que fred donc tu
oublies ça mais sur le coup je prends un
choc donc quand on me dit est ce que tu
lui en veut un peu évidemment que
j'avais un petit peu mais il est même
lui même un peu gêné de ce qu'il a fait
mais fred est un génie de la télé cette
émission est incroyable il fallait qu'il
parte avec en faisant salto arrière
c'est tombé sur moi
sauf que ce qu'on voit là je suis pas en
train de faire la comédie j'ai pris un
choc pour de vrai matteau si toi tu as
fait une émission d'aventuré aussi ah
oui avec encore on s'en rappelle ça tu
l'as toujours en tête c'est un souvenir
voilà je pensais c'est le même genre de
choses qu'on convient quoi on est on est
comme dit plus du tout dans notre zone
de confort on a pas on n'a plus de
repères on est fatigué on
on n'est jamais à un moment vraiment
quand comptez quand tu es vraiment au
bout quand les musiques menthe épuisé
que tu est déshydratée et seat et les
caméras temps n'a rien à faire alors on
va voir un extrait en exclusivité de
l'émission rendez vous en terre inconnue
avec franck gastambide regarde je
propose une expérience un peu extrême je
ne pars pas en terre inconnue
je
tu te rends compte c'est comme un mec
qui te dis allez viens on met dans une
cage arquin puis finalement tu le
pousser ya pas la cage
c'est exactement ce qu'un train de
m'arriver c'est à dire mais sécurité
m'ont mes repères
les seuls qui ya c'est que toi je suis
middle jetant veux me donne je t'en veux
je suis pas l'autre se trouve paul
gaultier bon instant qu arrêter bientôt
leur entrée les vidéos est ce qu'on va
dire à fred qui nous regardent ce soir
bah on s'expliquera devant les gens le
19 mars sur france 2 je vous êtes
vraiment parlé depuis ou pas du tout non
non mais après c'est un peu là un petit
froid
non il n'ya pas de froid je suis parti
avec quelqu'un d'autre finalement je le
connais peu ces frais dont on s'est
parlé on sait on s'est croisés dans des
festivals de cinéma comme un peu tout le
monde j'adore ce mec je rêvais de partir
avec lui je pars parce que c'est lui
et puis tu sais au moment où ils
m'annoncent je pars pas en terre
inconnue moi je me dis je vais partir
tout seul je connais toi tu croyais que
ça a été tu es jo tétouan trop dit non
mais imaginez que terre inconnue va être
avec un nouveau mec à ce moment là ça
n'a pas été aussi vide dans ma tête donc
ça a été un choc mais encore une fois
c'est tellement détails de ce qui se
passe après ça c'est cinq minutes de
terre inconnue du parti de 17 jours
coupés du monde
j'étais rencontrer des gens incroyables
qui avait jamais vu un blanc de peau de
leur vie qu'ils avaient jamais écouté de
musique jamais vu un film je leur ai dit
à un moment est ce que vous connaissez
quelqu'un de connu cyril hanouna michael
jackson et non ils connaissaient pas tu
vois ce que dire enfin
donc c'est un détail ce que gilles
verdez peut-être cesser la clairement la
plus grande aventure de ma vie mais qui
part sur un choc mais maintenant avec le
recul je sais que ça m'a mis dans une
situation de faiblesse encore plus
brutale qui fait que j'ai toujours pas
vu le film je sais que isabelle était la
personne autour de moi a vu le film
d'accord avec toi et toi tu as décidé tu
veux le voir le soir même de la livre
alors ça se fait pas tu sais d'habitude
l'événement
les artistes vont valider et puis ils
enlèvent des trucs s'il se trouve pas
bosser se trouve pas drôle et c'est à
moi je me suis dit là toute façon tu
peux pas faire plus confiance ce que je
fais là donc allons juste
rien que j'ai à cacher de ce que j'ai
vécu là-bas tu vois moi on m'a demandé
aussi si je me trouvais pas beau si je
me trouvais pas drôle dans les émissions
j'aurai tout en le dédiant à ce maillot
rennais